was playing a heavyweight champion
because he's not a big guy no he really
is more like a middleweight but Hogan
was I mean he wouldn't even be able to
end back in these days wouldn't be able
to make the UFC's weight limit the UFC
has a 265 pound cutoff for whatever
reason really yeah there's there's no
super heavyweight division in mmm oh
yeah there there's a super heavyweight
division it's possible but the UFC's
never implemented it so it's been
sanctioned there's a 265 and above but
the UFC's heavyweight division has a
cut-off right and a bunch of guys have
had a cut weight Brock's a big exam sure
Brock had a cut weight to make 265
Francis and gah no Tim Sylvia a few guys
have had to actually cut weight mark
hunt cut wait to make 265 mark Mark's
about walking around as if we're ducking
tank absolutely you know but I love
about sly like you know you go back to a
lot of people don't know that story I'm
sure you do you know how he wrote that
script a rocking would not sell it and
you get off your honor's like Ryan
O'Neal to play rock here someone called
Paul Newman I forget who it was I pee I
feel like it was Ryan O'Neal they wanted
Ryan O'Neal to play Rocky and he held
out he's like no I [ __ ] wrote this
this is me your vehicle and yeah that's
it that's the greatest example of being
positively unstoppable and owning it
like so that's just alone you know get
written this book or has a hundred
thousand times and when you know like
he's he's one of my mentors without me
knowing him you know because I've just
watched how he's lived his life and he
he's you know recreated himself so many
times and that's what I'm constantly
trying to do crazies of the guys doing
the Expendables as a [ __ ] action star
he's in his 7 d crazy the [ __ ] in their
70s is believable in an actual role this
is guys have like beat people up in
movies like suspension of disbelief I'll
let it slide right right but when you
see him doing it you like I kind of
believe it the guys are still jacked at
70 72 I think 73 years old whatever the
[ __ ] he is
I mean is he now 72 years old that's
[ __ ] insane
behind the scenes from Stone Cold Steve
Austin he was like he's a brother to me
like a real one like we lived together
we rode together one of my best friends
and he's doing the first Expendables and
he's doing
you know he's we talked about I guess
he's on the set for about you know a
couple of weeks by this time and he says
I'll tell you what day and you remember
every top alpha dog is in that first
movie because he grabbed the you know
the heavies of the heavy the guys about
the biggest names and Austin said in a
world of alpha dogs there is one number
one guy and his name is Sylvester
Stallone and he said when he were doing
the Hollywood fight in the back Stallone
was like come on bring it like meant it
he broke his [ __ ] right have you seen
his neck look up they did an x-ray of
his neck he's got these [ __ ] screws
keeping his spine together in his neck
he showed it on it was the dinar Blanco
or Letterman but he was on and they
showed an x-ray of his neck he broke his
[ __ ] neck doing that movie because he
was 68 at the time 69 and he's getting
thrown into a wall right and telling
Austin I was a tough son of a [ __ ] I
ain't just wring it ya want it to be
real I mean he is mean look he got
knocked out by Antonio Carver Antonio
Tarver in one of those Rocky movies
right right I mean I think he was deep
into his 60s and he got [ __ ] knocked
out there doing the boxing scenes were
they going over things and Tarver
cracked him I would kill to do a workout
with him and show him cuz he oh no one
works out harder than his neck so
[ __ ] fused together athletes the
bionic man look at that that's [ __ ]
crazy so he's getting three discs fused
together he might be a toughest guy
pound-for-pound age for a July this is
him four months
oh my god who was the other guy they
take your sunglass off probably look out
jack Diaz 72 sure
well I love the guy man I mean you know
I want to feel good just sit down and
watch a rocky movie no he's a super nice
guy like real like self-deprecating
loose laugh doesn't take himself
seriously at all no ego just joking
around easy like somebody heckled out is
like zel you mom real real nice guy too
yeah